OHHH! LOOK AT THAT!
IT'S BEAUTIFUL!
IT'S LIKE A CATHEDRAL.
THIS IS THE PERFECT PLACE
FOR US TO SET UP
A MORE PERMANENT CAMP.
OH! I LOVE IT!
ONE OF THE REASONS
THIS PLACE IS PERFECT
IS I CAN STRING
A COUPLE OF HAMMOCKS.
HAMMOCKS ARE GREAT
NOT JUST 'CAUSE THEY'RE COMFY...
THANK YOU, THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
...BUT IN AN UNFAMILIAR PLACE,
YOU DON'T REALLY WANT TO SLEEP
ON THE GROUND.
YOU DON'T WANT TO GIVE YOURSELF
SUCH EASY ACCESS
TO THINGS LIKE --
I DON'T KNOW --
CENTIPEDES AND SCORPIONS
AND OTHER THINGS
I DON'T WANT TO THINK ABOUT.
[ As Jamie ]
"ADAM, HOW COME YOU USED UP
ALL OUR GOOD DUCT-TAPE ROPE
ON THOSE HAMMOCKS?"
[ Normal voice ]
"JAMIE [SCOFFS] I'M STRANDED
ON A DESERTED ISLAND FOR WEEKS.
I WANT TO BE COMFORTABLE
WHEN I SLEEP."
[ As Jamie ] "I DON'T REALLY
CARE HOW I SLEEP.
"I COULD SLEEP ON A PILE
OF ROCKS AND MILLIPEDES.
I WOULDN'T CARE."
ALL RIGHT, HERE GOES NOTHING.
OH, OH, OH, OH, OHHH!
OH!
[ SIGHS ]
WOW, THIS IS
SERIOUSLY COMFORTABLE.
LIKE, I'M NOT EVEN KIDDING,
FROM TELEVISION COMFORTABLE.
[ LAUGHS ]
Narrator:
AS HOME RENOVATIONS GO,
IT'S A SOLID START,
BUT THERE'S MUCH MORE
TO THIS CASTAWAY CRIB
THAN GOOD HANG TIME.
OH, HELLO!
I'M SO GLAD YOU'VE STOPPED BY.
WELCOME TO BANYAN ESTATES.
CAN I GIVE YOU THE GRAND TOUR?
THIS IS
THE MASTER ACCOMMODATIONS
WITH THE MASTER BED AND SHELTER
AND RAIN CATCHER ALL IN ONE
WITH A NICE FOOT MAT
SO ONE CAN GET IN AND OUT OF BED
WITHOUT HAVING TO WEAR SHOES.
THE GUEST ACCOMMODATIONS
ARE ALMOST AS NICE
WITH A GUEST
RAIN CATCHER AND ROOF,
ALONG WITH EXTRA ROPE
FOR ANYTHING THAT NEEDS...ROPE.
IT'S ALL THE COMFORTS OF HOME
ON YOUR OWN DESERTED ISLAND.
Narrator: ADAM GOES
THE EXTRA MYTHBUSTERS MILE
BY BUILDING
A TABLE AND CHAIRS...
NOW FOR THE PIECES.
Narrator: ...AND A CHESS SET,
WHICH SHOULD GIVE
THEIR DUCT-TAPE CAMP
THAT LITTLE BIT OF LUXURY.
AH! AH! HEY!
GAAH!